the single most common refrain you've
heard from conservative politicians for
Generations since Eisenhower is that the
news media has a left-wing bias long
before Donald Trump went after fake news
Richard Nixon was telling his AIDS not
to talk to the New York Times in the
Washington Post new Gingrich insisted
that he didn't read letters to the
editor and newspapers because the
editors were all leftists Bob Dole
ignored questions about his views on
Tobacco because he didn't care what the
quote liberal media thought Republicans
have disparaged the media for so long um
because the media deserves it the vast
majority of news outlets in this country
are corrupt and partisan and everybody
knows it on both ends of the political
Spectrum so it's an easy target to hit
over and over and over and over again
the problem with this approach isn't
that it's wrong I mean it's it's correct
they're right about what they're saying
about the news media the problem is that
it doesn't go nearly far enough it
doesn't come close to addressing the
extent of the bias the ideological
capture in American Media yes corporate
news media is propaganda from The New
York Times to NBC to CNN and the
Washington Post and so on we know that
but the news media is just part of a
much much larger issue what
conservatives almost never talked about
for decades is that this bias also
exists in other forms of media where it
is in fact much more Insidious and
harmful and most notably in children's
programming you know that's a that's a
much bigger deal than bias and
mainstream news coverage for reasons
that should be obvious adults who are
the primary audience for news coverage
have more mature brains than children at
least some of us do they're generally
capable of recognizing propaganda when
they see it or they should be capable of
it anyway but children for the most part
don't have that ability if Nickelodeon
bombards them with non-binary characters
and if Disney hits them with a not so
secret gay agenda which they've admitted
is their goal then kids are totally
vulnerable to it they're
helpless and also on top of that
entertainment as opposed to uh news
media Burrows deeper into the human soul
and psyche it can shape you in ways that
a CNN News segment simply cannot much to
CNN's Chagrin conservative politicians
and other thought leaders somehow rarely
seem to notice this problem for a long
time with very few exceptions they
didn't say much about it but parents all
over the country have been aware of
what's going on for a while and that
became uh especially clear to me a
couple of weeks ago when I decided to do
a monologue opening the show um uh about
LGBT propaganda in the show PAW Patrol
which is one of the most popular
television shows for children and I went
into some detail about pa Paw Patrol's
newest writer who's this creepy activist
who makes sing songy videos for kids
about abortion and
transgenderism you know often in the
past when I have led the show with a
topic like that instead of say the war
in Ukraine or now the war in Israel or
the 50th Trump indictment or whatever um
typically there's there there's been
some backlash you can you can usually
count on a few people or more than a few
to say that it's a silly topic and that
grown men shouldn't pay attention to
Children's shows anyway and of course
the left always says that because they
don't want you talking about what
they're doing to children they recognize
how important it is they pretend that
they don't because they don't want you
to notice but
historically this has been the response
from the right as well there have always
been you know a decent number of
conservatives who just don't want to
hear about any topic that isn't a
headline on cable
news um and meanwhile their children
their own children are being shaped and
changed and
transformed in front of them under their
nose uh while they're only paying
attention to whatever Fox news is
talking
about now this time though the reaction
was very different from the norm I'm not
going to go through all the comments
that listeners and readers left about
that monologue you can read them
yourself if you like on the daily wire
website but the consensus was pretty
much unanimous people are completely fed
up with the endless stream of propaganda
that corporate media is directing at
their children in the form of these kid
shows it's not just Paw Patrol I mean
it's everywhere it's everything there
were hundreds of comments along these
lines and and um many of them specified
specific shows that have begun
shoehorning left-wing agenda items into
their plot lines a lot of shows that
I've never heard of because as I've said
before uh the vast majority of
children's programming has just been
ruled out completely in my house either
because it is it is leftwing garbage or
because it's just garbage per period
it's terrible quality and it'll make my
kids dumber and I don't want them
watching it or often times it's a
combination of the two and this is a
problem that affects all children's
programming these days or almost all of
it but no Titan of Children's
Entertainment has fallen in the public
eye quite like the Walt Disney Company
for Generations Disney made creative
content for children that mirrored the
values of their parents and their
country they weren't making these tepid
lifeless politically correct liveaction
remakes they were coming out with um
animated films Timeless stories like
Snow White the Lion King Peter Pan but
in recent years Disney's objectives have
changed and this is just not the same
company that existed in the 20th century
not even close things are now so bad
that Disney recently signed an agreement
to create propaganda films for China's
Ministry of culture which is a good fit
we have to admit a radically left-wing
company making propaganda for a
communist government that is a match
made in Hell meanwhile in this country
without even attempting to hide what
they're doing Disney has begun the A and
long ago began a top- down effort to
indoctrinate children into left-wing
ideologies especially gender ideology
which invariably involves the
sexualization of children this is now
what Disney stands for at every level
last year as you may remember the
journalist Chris rufo published a
footage of uh of Disney meetings and
what they were talking about behind the
scenes and they were very open about
this agenda here's one clip if you
didn't see it of Disney corporate
president Carrie Burke speaking in a in
this virtual meeting with her colleagues
and uh it's disturbing but it shows just
how ingrained this ideology is at Disney
watch I'm here as a mother of of two
queer children actually um uh one
transgender child um um and one
pansexual child um and and also as a
leader um and that was the thing that
really got me because I have heard so
much from so many of my colleagues over
the course of the last couple weeks um
in open forums and through emails and
phone conversations
and um I feel a responsibility to speak
um not just for myself but for them um
to all of us we had a we had an open
Forum last week at 20th where um again
the home of of really incredible
groundbreaking
lgbtqia stories over the years where um
one of our execs stood up and said you
know we only have a handful of queer
leads in our content and I went what I
that can't be true and I and I and I
realized oh it it actually is true we
have many many many lgbtq qia characters
in our stories and and and yet we don't
have enough
leads we don't have enough It's never
enough you know nothing is ever gay
enough for these people especially this
woman who claimed to have one child who
is quote pansexual and another who
identifies as quote unquote transgender
and if you have any basic understanding
of Statistics you know exactly what that
means I mean there's just no way that uh
one parent ends up with two kids who
both just happen to identify this way uh
what it means is this woman is foisting
gender ideology on her own children and
she's proud of it she's happy that she
programmed her kids this way and now uh
she wants to program yours as well that
woman is not alone at Disney as you
might imagine another video obtained by
rufo a Disney executive producer
explained that she has a not at all
secret gay agenda and regularly works on
adding queerness to Children's
programming and that's an Infamous
enough clip that we don't need to play
it you've probably seen it by now but it
is uh it's Infamous for a reason and
there are many more like it though in
truth you don't need to listen in on
Disney's staff meetings to see what the
company is doing you just watch their
content the left-wing activists at glad
the gay and lesbian alliance against
defamation have been doing that and
they've taken notice of Disney's
activism they just praise Disney for
adding quote lgbtq content into more
than 40% of their Productions last year
so this is overt LGBT indoctrination
even according to Glad in 40% of the
children shows just in one year and that
beat out every other company except uh
except Netflix Netflix is still gayer
than Disney just by a hair though you
know we do things very differently here
at the daily wire we host several of the
top news podcasts in the world we
launched a chocolate company overnight
we just took Disney head-on by releasing
100 episodes of kids content it takes
very specific people with very specific
skills to make the daily wire what it is
how do we find and hire these people
well we do that with zi recuiter that's
how zi recutter makes your whole hiring
process faster and easier their powerful
technology works for you to identify
people whose skills and experience match
your job zi recruiter saves you Time by
letting you easily invite your top
candidates to apply to your job so
they're more likely to apply sooner zip
recruiter is trusted by millions in fact
over 3.8 million business businesses
have come to zi recruiter uh for their
hiring needs make a positive impact on
your hiring future with zi recruiter
four to five employers who post on zi
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the first day go to zi recruit.com wals
to try zi recruiter for free again
that's zi recruiter.com
wsh zi recuiter the smartest way to
hire it's important to note here that
Disney they're not simply trying to uh
sexualize kids and hit them with LGBT
propaganda
uh which is bad enough on its own
obviously they're also trying to instill
in them all of the values of the modern
left to make them as insufferable and
entitled as possible to that end Disney
hired a truly obnoxious woman to play
Snow White in this upcoming feminist
adaptation of the classic film I showed
you some of her footage before it's hard
to watch so I'll spare you that as well
parents in this country see all this
happening uh they don't need it explain
to them anymore as Disney's perverse
agenda has taken hold a lot of these
parents have uh been giving up on the
whole brand last year Disney posted its
worst stock return in 48 years losing
nearly half its value According to some
analysts Disney's attacks on
conservative values have cost them
roughly a billion dollars when you
consider some of their recent box office
returns when they've just been putting
out flop after flop after flop flop now
to be clear uh these numbers aren't
simply a reflection of the poor quality
of Disney's latest Productions although
it's certainly that as well parents
understand what Disney stands for and
it's it's a it's an ideology that
parents don't want anywhere near their
children there was a brand new survey
from Ras M reports recently which the
daily wire reported on uh which shows
that as of late September more than 60%
of GOP voters view Disney unfavorably
more than a third say they view Disney
very unfavorably now these are
staggering numbers especially when you
consider that that that the numbers are
somehow even lower than the favorability
ratings of Bud Light which has suffered
maybe the single greatest collapse of
any brand in modern history
but there is one unique advantage that
Disney has enjoyed despite its free fall
and popularity and that's the fact that
their brand of indoctrination is
everywhere in children's media I mean
it's just totally ubiquitous with
budlight people could buy a different
brand of beer with kids content that has
been virtually impossible whether you
stick with Disney or you go to
Nickelodeon or wherever else you go
you're going to encounter the same
garbage and so parents said well there's
nowhere else where else else am I there
are no other
options and that is all why a little
over a year ago the daily wire announced
our plans to invest a minimum of $100
million over the next three years into a
line of live action and animated
children's entertainment and with that
decision the daily wire became the only
major Media company that has ever
decided to do anything about the
wholesale all-encompassing left-wing
bias that has now infected every aspect
of children's media yesterday we
delivered on that promise on the 100th
anniversary the day Walt Disney founded
his company the daily wire launched bent
key which is a brand new company with
its own app uh you can go on your Apple
TV Google Play Roku fire stick and
download it right now there's 150
episodes available at the moment new
ones coming out every Saturday morning
as we resurrect the Saturday morning
cartoon that uh many of us grew up with
there's even a new liveaction Snow White
movie coming from beny featuring our
very own Brett Cooper which will
actually respect and stay faithful to
the original fairy tale and of course
with all due respect to Brett Cooper the
biggest news I think is that I make a
key Cameo appearance in one of our new
animated children's shows called chip
Chilla I play a talking dinosaur to toy
um and this is incredible footage as
well watch
this detecting nothing of interest on
this planet you got that right Bronto no
way I will find anything valuable around
here
I shall defeat Captain Bronto for he is
weak and I am less weak punch
punch what oh
[Music]
no wow what a staggering and beautiful
performance by me I only have one line
but I deliver it with such skill and
force in Artistry that it practically
brings you to tears this is what many
people are saying anyway at least it's
what I said when I watched that episode
with my kids last night and uh I'll be
honest that my daughter talked over my
line so I had to rewind it and play it
again and say everyone be quiet for a
second listen to
this and make sure everyone heard it uh
nobody in my living room reacted very
much or seemed overly impressed with my
performance but that's because they were
stunned into silence I asked if they
wanted to go back and watch the scene
again they said no they wanted to watch
another episode um probably because it
was the performance was so powerful that
they they couldn't emotionally cope with
witnessing it again
anyway aside from the one single line I
contributed I can report that the rest
of the children's content is truly
terrific it's exactly what so many
parents have been waiting for I'm not
just saying that because I work here I'm
saying that because I'm a father of six
and I'm one of those parents we spent a
couple of hours last night as a family
going through the app and watching
different shows the kids loved all of it
I was personally very impressed
beautiful animation good stories
conservative values all the things that
most modern Children's Entertainment
lacks and when I say conservative values
I don't mean that the shows are
political or that they hit you over the
head with right-wing ideology which is
usually again historically when
conservatives get into entertainment
that's what it means it means that uh
listen everyone this is conservative
here's the conservative lesson check it
out guys just battering you over the
head with a sledgehammer that's not the
case here I mean that they are stories
centered around Timeless truths and and
virtues courage patience faithfulness
love of family and so on these are
conservative values they are the values
that we're trying to conserve and that
the modern entertainment industry has
been waging a war against for many years
now this may seem like one long
commercial for our kids content and I
suppose it is but nobody told me I had
to talk about this and I don't
personally get paid when you subscribe
to our children's platform I'm talking
about it because I truly believe in it I
think it's extremely important the fact
that Children's Entertainment is
entirely captured by the left is a it's
a major problem and nobody has made any
serious effort to do anything about it
until now and I'm proud we're in that
fight one of many that we have picked as
a company you know we take a lot of flak
uh here at the daily wire we get it from
the left as you would expect we're also
attacked very frequently from the right
everybody has a gripe a complaint a nit
to pick one minute we're farri fascist
bigot extremist the next minute where
milk toast establishment uh leftist in
Disguise depending on who you're
listening to because people love to uh
sit up in the bleachers at a distance
and criticize everyone has a
criticism but we're down here in the
arena taking the risks trying to
actually make a difference don't always
get it right make mistakes sometimes
don't win every
battle okay with the kids content it's
fantastic it's amazing I
think um is it success guaranteed not at
all people need to support it if they
don't could be a disastrous failure
could take the whole company down given
the amount of financial investment we've
put into
it but it's worth the
risk because we're down here on the
ground in the fight which is the only
place that I personally want to
be if You' like to see what else I have
to say you can access my full show by
going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope see
you there godp speed